Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
« Bateau,
je t’aime parce que tu m’offres
la plus belle jeunesse du monde.
Tu m’accordes les éléments,
les rencontres,
les joies naïves et essentielles,
les plaisirs sensuels.
Tu m’apportes l’amitié et l’assurance
que, quand je serai grand,
je saurai encore être enfant. »
Par mon accent, vous avez peut-être
remarqué que je viens d’ailleurs.
Mais j’ai appris le français
pour pouvoir lire des livres.
A l’époque, je ne savais pas qu’un jour,
j’allais vivre en France,
vivre en français,
qu’un jour j’allais venir ici et parler
devant vous tous, dans votre langue.
Et je ne savais pas non plus qu’un jour,
je préparerais en France
mes propres projets de navigation.
J’ai connu la mer grâce à l’absence
qu’elle me causait,
l’absence et le manque de mon père.
Mon père était un navigateur solitaire
et pendant des mois, il partait
très, très loin de la maison.
On vivait avec cette absence,
avec ce manque.
On se posait la question
de pourquoi il laissait la maison
alors qu’il aurait pu rester avec nous.
Et quand il rentrait, enfants,
on était très contentes.
Il nous racontait les rencontres
qu’il avait faites
avec ces animaux géants
qui émergeaient du fond de l’eau
et qui étaient pourtant très gentils.
Il nous décrivait ces cathédrales
faites de glaçons
qui étaient plus grandes que notre maison,
qui étaient plus grandes
que notre quartier.
Il nous parlait de ces vents
qui étaient tellement forts
qu’ils pouvaient faire voler
des êtres humains.
Moi, je regardais les plis
des draps de notre lit
et j’imaginais que
ces plis étaient les vagues
qu’il retrouvait quand il était en bateau.
J’imaginais que les vents
qui rentraient par la fenêtre
étaient les vents très forts
des mers du Sud.
Tout ça me faisait beaucoup rêver
d’y être aussi un jour.
Quand j’avais huit ans,
j’ai eu la chance de faire partie
d’un de ses voyages.
Ma maman et mon papa ont mis
mes sœurs et moi dans son bateau.
Et on est allés en Antarctique ensemble.
Et cela m’a apporté un traumatisme
duquel je n’ai jamais su me libérer.
Ce traumatisme était lié
au fait que j’ai découvert
que tous ses récits étaient réels,
que ces vagues existaient vraiment,
que ces icebergs étaient vraiment énormes,
et que ces animaux, ils pouvaient
passer juste à côté de notre bateau.
Sur la photo, c’est ma sœur
sur un Optimist,
un petit bateau sur lequel on a appris
à naviguer dans un réservoir,
un étang près de la ville
où je suis née, Sao Paulo.
Sao Paulo,
c’est un peu la New York du Brésil.
Donc on peut se dire que
ce n’est pas l’endroit le plus inspirant
pour quelqu’un
qui veut devenir navigateur.
Pour ne pas oublier mon rêve,
j’ai construit une forteresse
de bouquins autour de moi.
Quand je lisais ces livres,
ça me rappelait à chaque fois
que ces rêves étaient possibles
parce qu’il y avait des gens de mon âge
de plusieurs endroits du monde
qui en étaient en train de les vivre.
A chaque fois, il fallait que
je me rappelle que c’était possible
parce que quand je prenais
le chemin entre l’école et la maison,
je passais par les embouteillages,
j’aurais pu l’oublier.
Un jour, j’ai décidé
de faire mon propre projet.
J’avais treize ans.
À l’époque, j’ai fait une liste
avec tout ce dont j’allais avoir besoin
pour faire un voyage en solitaire.
Après, j’ai pris rendez-vous
avec mon père au petit déjeuner.
Je lui demande si éventuellement
il me laisserait partir toute seule.
Il dit que oui.
Je lui demande si éventuellement
son bateau allait être disponible
pour faire une navigation.
Il dit que oui, que
son bateau serait disponible.
Je lui demande s’il peut me prêter son
bateau, pour que je navigue toute seule,
Il me regarde et me dit :
« Tamara. Bien sûr que non.
(Rires)
Jamais de la vie
je ne te prêterai mon bateau.
Si tu veux naviguer toute seule,
il faut que tu fasses ton propre chemin.
Il faut que tu trouves
un moyen de faire un bateau
ou de trouver un bateau où tu peux.
Il faut que tu apprennes par toi-même.
Il faut que tu ailles chercher
tes propres maîtres
parce que moi je n’ai rien te donner.
Je ne veux pas te donner de conseils,
ni de bateau,
je ne veux pas te donner d’argent.
Je vais t’aider avec zéro centime. »
Il a fait comme ça : zéro !
« Zéro conseil, zéro suggestion.
Tu m’appelles juste pour dire
quand tu seras arrivée. »
Bon. J’étais un peu déçue.
J’ai trouvé qu’il n’était pas
très généreux avec moi.
Plus tard, j’ai commencé à faire
des études d’architecture
parce que je me disais
que j’avais des projets à faire.
Les cours qui m’apprendraient à faire
des projets étaient ceux d’architecture.
Plus tard, je suis allée en France pour
faire des études d’architecture navale.
J’ai galéré avec le français.
J’avais un niveau de français
suffisant pour lire un bouquin,
mais pas exactement pour parler.
Au départ, je comptais sur la générosité
de mes collègues pour m’expliquer
parce que j’avais du mal
à comprendre les phrases.
Plus tard, j’ai appris qu’en partant
de l’école et en allant à ma maison,
les rues que je prenais à Nantes avaient
les noms des navigateurs que j’avais lus.
En France, j’avais l’impression
que mes rêves étaient plus possibles.
Donc je n’ai pas voulu partir de France.
Quelques années plus tard,
pendant le confinement,
je venais de rompre avec la personne
que je croyais être l’amour de ma vie.
À 23 ans.
Ça arrive.
Je n’avais plus de maison,
puisqu’on vivait ensemble.
J’ai décidé de répondre à un mail
qu’un follower de YouTube m’avait envoyé.
C’était un mec
qui avait l’air d’être un peu fou,
qui me disait : « Tamara,
j’ai un bateau que je n’utilise jamais.
Si tu veux, tu peux venir
utiliser mon bateau.
Sauf que j’habite en Norvège, à Alesund. »
Je ne savais même pas
où Alesund était sur la carte,
mais au moment où je n’avais plus rien,
c’était peut-être le moment
de prendre des risques
parce que je n’avais vraiment
pas grand-chose à perdre.
A ce moment-là, je pars en Norvège avec
des plus ou moins connaissances à lui
qu’il avait trouvées
dans le groupe Facebook.
En arrivant là-bas en bateau, il me dit
qu’en fait il avait changé d’avis,
qu’il ne voulait plus
me prêter son bateau.
C’était la deuxième fois
que ça m’arrivait,
je commençais à être habituée.
Au lieu de ça, il allait m’aider
à trouver mon propre bateau
pour que je parte naviguer toute seule
parce qu’il croyait que c’était
seulement en ayant le bateau,
en étant propriétaire du bateau,
que j’allais réussir
à prendre des décisions
sans avoir besoin de demander
son avis à personne.
C’est comme ça que j’allais avoir
besoin d’apprendre plus vite
parce que j’allais payer pour mes erreurs.
On apprend plus vite quand on doit payer
pour chaque faute qu’on fait.
On commence à chercher un bateau.
J’ai trouvé un bateau qui était dans
un fjord de Norvège depuis 30 ans.
Il n’était pas trop grand :
il faisait huit mètres.
C’était un bateau un peu de week-end.
Je discute avec les propriétaires.
Ils acceptent de me le vendre
au prix d’un vélo.
C’était très bien parce que
je n’avais même pas ça.
Puis, je pars de Norvège
pour aller en France.
Pendant un mois, j’ai préparé ce bateau.
Je ne l’ai raconté à personne parce que
j’étais sûre que, si j’appelais ma maman,
si je racontais ce que j’allais faire,
j’allais abandonner,
car elle allait dire
que la mer était trop dangereuse,
que je n’avais jamais fait ça,
que ça n’allait pas marcher.
Je protège mon rêve.
Je n’en parle qu’à des gens
dont j’étais sûre qu’ils allaient dire
que ça allait bien se passer.
Je ne savais pas qu’en Norvège,
il y avait autant de cailloux.
Mais j'apprends vite.
Le 1er soir, je tape un caillou.
Deuxième, je perds le support
du pilote automatique.
Je dois rester à la barre
pendant des heures et des heures.
On apprend vite à faire pipi sur le
cockpit si on ne peut pas lâcher la barre.
On s’habitue parce que quand
c’est à nous de régler les problèmes,
on accepte de faire plus de compromis.
J’étais toute seule,
donc ce n’était pas trop problématique.
Je ne savais pas non plus que,
quand on navigue dans les fjords,
soit le vent [souffle fort],
soit il n’y en a plus du tout.
Et donc je mettais toutes les voiles,
après je les enlevais toutes, etc.
J’ai appris en arrivant en France
que mes mains,
même si elles ne sont pas très grandes,
étaient capables de faire
plus que ce que je pensais,
et que mes bras, même s’ils ne sont
pas trop costauds - vous le remarquez -
ils pouvaient aussi faire plus d’efforts
que ce que je croyais.
J’ai décidé d’aller un peu plus loin :
jusqu’au Brésil.
C’était un voyage -
(Applaudissements)
Ça allait être un voyage
quatre fois plus long.
Mais au moins, j’avais déjà
navigué un petit peu avant.
J’appelle mon pote Henrique - c’est
lui qui m’a aidée à acheter le bateau -
et il me dit : « Tamara, peut-être
que tu devrais changer de bateau,
parce que maintenant, le voyage
sera un peu plus grand aussi.
Tu as fait des vidéos YouTube
sur la route,
il y a peut-être plus de moyens
de trouver des sponsors.
- Henrique, tu es fou !
Moi, j’ai le meilleur bateau
que je peux avoir.
C’est le bateau que je connais déjà.
Donc on va rester avec Sardinha -
sardine - c’est le nom du bateau -
jusqu’à la fin.
On va voir jusqu’où Sardinha peut aller. »
Très bien.
Heureusement, je n’étais
jamais complètement seule
parce qu’à chaque fois où je me suis
arrêtée, je faisais des belles rencontres.
Je comptais sur l’aide des pêcheurs,
des caissières des supermarchés,
des touristes qui passaient.
Même ceux qui n’avaient
pas forcément envie de m’aider,
au final, étaient un peu
obligés de m’aider,
des fois par générosité,
des fois par pitié.
Mais ça marchait très bien.
Pendant la navigation,
je me suis arrêtée dans quelques endroits
où je me suis fait plein de copains.
J’ai aussi eu quelques difficultés,
notamment au niveau du Pot au noir.
C’est une région près
de la ligne de l’équateur
où il y a beaucoup
d’instabilité météorologique.
Je pensais que c’était problématique
parce qu’il n’y a pas de vent,
mais je ne savais pas
qu’il y avait ces gros nuages noirs
qui peuvent passer
et qui amènent beaucoup de pluie
et beaucoup de vent
qui tourne dans tous les sens.
Sur ça, je n’avais pas
été trop bien briefée.
Mais c’était peut-être une des raisons
pour lesquelles j’ai fait ce voyage.
Je pense que,
si j’avais su l’ampleur des défis auxquels
je devais faire face quand je suis partie,
je ne serais jamais partie.
En fait, je n’aurais jamais appris
que je pouvais les surmonter.
Le jour où j’ai pris cette photo,
il y avait du vent qui tournait dans
tous les sens, très fort puis très faible.
Il y avait la mer qui montait,
elle couvrait tout le bateau
et il y avait de l’eau
à l’intérieur tout le temps,
il fallait que je la sorte avec -
je ne connais pas le nom de cet objet,
mais vous avez compris.
J’ai passé toute la nuit
à sortir l’eau du bateau
et à essayer de régler le bateau.
Les pilotes automatiques,
ils ont cramé très vite.
D’abord le premier, après le deuxième.
Après, je n’avais plus de pilote,
je n’avais plus de lumière,
plus de feux de navigation.
Il fallait que j’y trouve un moyen
de montrer aux bateaux que j’étais là.
Je n’avais plus d’antenne de VHF.
Au final, j’ai appris
que, quand on navigue,
plus important que d’être prêt
pour faire la navigation
et d’imaginer tous les défis
qu’on peut y trouver,
c’est d’être prêt à résoudre les problèmes
auxquels on ne s’est pas préparé.
C’est un peu comme la vie, je pense.
Et quand les choses allaient très mal,
je me disais :
« Tamara, ne t’inquiète pas, reste calme,
parce que dans le futur,
ça sera bien pire.
(Rires)
Dans le futur,
la mer sera plus grande, les vagues
seront plus fortes, le vent aussi.
Il va y avoir beaucoup
plus d’accélération.
Peut-être qu’il y aura des icebergs,
peut-être que tu seras
encore plus fatiguée.
Profite de l’instant,
il ne fait même pas trop froid,
c’est la ligne d’équateur.
Donc le bateau avance ; ça passe.
Tu as peut-être l’habitude,
tu es brésilienne. »
C’est comme ça
que j’ai traversé ces défis.
Le jour de cette photo, il manquait
encore une semaine pour arriver.
J’avais envie d’abandonner.
J’ai regardé la carte.
J’ai regardé cette carte
en essayant de trouver l’endroit le
plus proche vers où je pouvais m’enfuir.
C’était déjà la ville de Recife
qui était la destination.
finale que j’avais choisie.
Donc ça tombait très bien
car personne n’était au courant que
j’avais abandonné quand je suis arrivée.
Du coup, je continue -
(Applaudissements)
Ça, c’est la photo que
ma maman a prise quand j’arrivais.
Très bien.
Il faut savoir qu’elle a dû prendre
le téléphone de quelqu’un d’autre
parce qu’au moment de la photo,
je croyais qu’elle serait là
en train de m’attendre,
mais elle était en train
de faire un live à ses followers.
(Rires)
J’ai aussi appris en arrivant
qu’apparemment, j’étais très suivie
sur les réseaux sociaux.
Heureusement que je ne le savais pas
parce que j’étais moins stressée
quand je faisais des tours sur la carte.
Quand je commence
à voir les feux de Recife,
il y a un bateau qui s’approche de moi.
J’entends la voix de ma maman qui criait :
« Ça ne peut pas être elle,
ça ne peut pas être Tamara,
parce que le bateau est trop petit. »
(Rires)
OK... Je continue,
je passe devant la ville de Recife.
Il y avait plein de gens qui attendaient.
Je croyais qu’il y avait un match de foot.
Mais c’était pour me voir.
Je n’avais plus de pilote automatique,
donc c’était un peu galère de rester là
et de faire salut aux gens.
(Rires)
Ma plus grande crainte,
c’était comment faire
pour affaler les voiles.
Parce que je n’ai pas trois mains,
je ne peux pas courir.
Il y a des constructions autour.
J’étais habituée à naviguer
sans trop regarder
parce qu’il n’y avait rien
autour de moi dans l’Atlantique.
J’étais un peu fatiguée.
Je commence à m’approcher du port,
je vois qu’il y a une journaliste.
Je vois mon papa.
Mon papa, c’est une personne assez
connue dans la navigation au Brésil.
Elle s’approche de lui et lui demande :
« Alors Amyr, est-ce que tu es fier
de ce que ta fille a fait ? »
J’ai appris depuis que j’étais
la personne la plus jeune du Brésil
à avoir fait une transat en solitaire.
Donc mon papa -
(Applaudissements)
Mon papa répond :
« Je suis très impressionné
parce qu’elle a fait un grand voyage
avec un bateau très précaire. »
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
C’est sûr que si j’avais pu choisir
entre tous les bateaux du monde,
ce n’est peut-être pas Sardinha
que j’aurais choisi,
mais Sardinha m’a appris
une leçon très importante
que je n’aurais pas apprise autrement.
C’est le bateau qui m’a donné
l’opportunité d’essayer
et pour ça, je serai toujours
très reconnaissante.
La leçon qu’elle m’a apprise, c’est qu’on
pouvait faire beaucoup avec très peu
et qu’on pouvait aller très loin
avec ce qu’on avait déjà.
Et ça, c'est l'exercice de notre temps.
Public : Bravo !
(Applaudissements)
Merci.